[Music]
the new world order's dead the left is
dead hollywood is dead and matthew
mcconaughey can't put their humpty
dumpty system back together again
so they can pin it all on
celebrities they can all be delusional
people broken with the system we know
the social contracts broken
it's not about right wing it's not about
left-wing it's about common sense and
prosperity and we are done with the
liberal new world order and and again i
have no beef against matthew economy i
mean it's really hurtful for me to have
to come out here and declare war on him
but i'm not going to sit here while that
son of a [ __ ] takes my birthright and
pisses all over it and shits all over it
uh and so i'm sure if you put the clip
out it'll go viral i'll be exposing him
but it's all true i'll stand up at a
court of law he's a known drug a known
drug addict but i wanted to go viral i
wanted to go down i'm okay we want
people to know this the problem is alex
is that at this point you've been right
more than you've been wrong you know and
when you've been wrong you've admitted
it so at this point it's like look
here's something i wanted to say like
how many times have you been on a plane
and some guy like taps you and you turn
and they're like you were right about
the frogs yeah
alex jones was right and the alex jones
is right t-shirt is available at
infowarsstore.com
and and
and i'm not just plugging something
because i need money to phone this
operation
literally you wear an alex jones's right
shirt it is an incredible adventure
and yeah no i mean we're here for the
worm turning we've actually witnessed uh
the whole thing happen
and you guys are right but i'm telling
you the power structure's dead no matter
how much they triple down nothing's
working what do you predict is going to
happen now that nobody's buying anything
they can say and they think a drug
addict like matthew mcconaughey is going
to be their savior i i think that here's
what's happening and i mean i think that
there's some glimmer of hope because
we've been seeing a lot of normies that
normally even are political starting to
turn and go like this is getting crazy
like yeah now it's affecting my life now
it's affecting my life like it's one
thing when you know it's and we said it
on the show and it's not just because
you're on like you know to suck up to
you but this is true we said it when you
were banned from everything we were like
all these people are cheating i'm like
it's gonna start with him and then you
know what's gonna happen it's gonna be
you and now they're banning jordan
peterson off of twitter everybody off of
twitter screaming about him like you
didn't care when it when it wasn't you
and that brings me to this question the
one thing i never thought i would hear
in 2022
is somebody on fox news not only talk
about you but praise you tucker has been
mentioning you quite a bit lately and i
was wondering what you thought about
that yeah
well if i'm friends with tucker i'll
leave it at that
um you know we hang out and stuff and uh
he's a populist he's a smart guy he's
really smart and i like him uh and uh
you know i'm banned on fox and of course
he tried to have me on and they said we
don't care he he actually took a lot
less money to do whatever he wants
and we went and said well my contract
says i can do whatever i want they said
well you don't care what your contract
says you ain't have any money so that's
kind of what that is but but but
it's kind of cooler to be banned and and
be the guy in the phantom zone but
you know you know getting back to where
we are politically and where the world
is right now
it's the system that did all this it's
the system that screwed us over and the
establishment that's hated so they could
ban you ban me ban joe rogan tomorrow
it's not going to matter because
everyone knows they're being lied to we
don't want the great reset we don't want
klaus schwab flying around a private jet
with uh bill gates and and prince
charles while we go bankrupt and we're
just not buying it so they're trying to
run an agenda of feudalism
in the 21st century and it may have
worked 500 years ago but the renaissance
said record skip car wreck sound no
and so they're trying to run a play they
ran before and it ain't going to work
what it's going to cause is a big war
and uh maybe the end of the world so we
are in very very exciting times right
now
yeah we are looking exciting is a good
adjective so something's going to change
because i think we are really at that
boiling point right where it's that's it
like
something something massive is going to
have to happen because
never we've never been this divided i've
never seen people this completely
divided the government is now you know
again something else that everyone used
to be like oh alex jones thinks there's
going to be fema camps i'm like well
yeah they literally they're literally
australia was doing there have been fema
they've been fema camps before
and and now they're they're building
them in in in the us
they're building them in the uk they're
building them in in canada yeah i mean
look hey folks keep laughing alex jones
you're living what i told you because
people go
is jones one of this is my biggest
frustration
it's not just the establishment
attacking me or the democrats attacking
me if you go to twitter or facebook
anywhere i get it every day it's he
knows all this because he's one of them
uh no
you can go reads abigail brzezinski's
books you can go read klaus swaps books
you can go watch the davos group they're
on there saying you'll own nothing
you'll have nothing you'll like it
you're going to eat bugs you're going to
drink sewage these are quotes
and i'm going this is horrible these
people are horrible and they're going to
do this and they had like operation
lockstep and all these drills that were
down to the day what they would do and
how they would do it i started watching
how everything they said in the document
was day to day the plan because they
have to do a drill
because if they announce their plan they
go to jail but if it's a drill
which is really a battle plan
like like imagine you have a script the
cops pull you over and you're driving
erratically and there's some blood on
the windshield whatever and they found a
dead body in the uh trunk a little kid
i don't know where that little kid came
from they get it and they go what's this
they open up a diary where you say i
kidnapped little jenny from her backyard
and took her and raped her for two weeks
then i killed her you you get to you get
the electric chair you get the lethal
injection but if it was
my script how i kidnapped jenny and
raped her and killed her oh it's a
script for a movie doesn't matter little
jenny's in the back of the car doesn't
matter her blood's all over the place
and there's there's there's there's
scrapes from her fingernails in your
chest as long as you say oh
that was just a movie so they do drills
and they do these war games as their
battle plan and then they launch it
that's what you need to look into
operation northwoods
um operation lockstep
spars
2025-2028 folks these aren't just things
i'm saying look them up and then you'll
be in my mind when you reach sparse 20
25 2028 it's 2000 2023 it's like virus
comes out of china attacks the repertory
system here's the tweets we put out when
it happens then we have then we have
them wear masks to create fear it says
this and then we have lockdowns and then
and then a year later we admit the
vaccine doesn't work and then we do this
then it collapses society and no one
believes in it and the the tweets
hundreds of them
are the exact tweets they put out later
they wrote this in in 2018
and then in 2000 it's the exact tweets
except they changed the acronyms so you
move the letters and it's the same
headline
so criminals love to brag they literally
wrote a battle plan spars 2025 2028 that
is the operative operation for what
they're doing some people go hell does
jones know what's coming next these
frickin psychos have a playbook you know
take the new england patriots
of course they paid people for the
playbooks of course they cheated to win
all the teams are cheating they just
cheated better and if you're conspiracy
theorist if you say the newland patriots
cheated of course they cheated that's
why they won they're all cheating they
cheated the best but
they got the playbooks so we got the
playbooks that's why i know this
that's a good explanation for it yeah i
have a question about um
this just popped in my head too
uh you're trending often on twitter
whether you're there or not you trend
very often so you were trending one day
and i looked and it was a video you
from like 10 15 years ago when you were
on jesse ventura's conspiracy theory
show
and you were explaining basically
exactly what's happening now to him 15
years ago
and it was like you just explained in
detail like you can create a pandemic
then i can create you know a lockdown
and then have a reaction to the pandemic
and blah blah blah it's all in this
playbook
and jesse ventura's just the whole time
going wow that's crazy and then now how
do you feel he's 15 years later he's on
rt going just get the shot all right
just shut up and don't question it and
get the shot it's like
what happened to him why what he what do
you think
where do you think he went wrong because
he was pushing that's a great way to end
this interview so here's the deal
i grew up watching jesse ventura with
hulk hogan and like team i knew it was
fake
and
then i had him as a guest when he was a
governor
and
then i was
one of the main advisors the first two
seasons
of his successful tv show
conspiracy theory
and
but
i i don't want to say he's dumb but he
just goes with the flow
and so i think he reads whatever's put
in front of him so you look at that
first season particularly on fema camps
the new world order all that that's 100
documented and i i basically wrote
almost all of that i sat down and said
here's this clip here's this interview
here's general stumblemine here's dr
rima labo here's who you interview and
he went and did it and then the third
season they said hey we may even have
you host the season if you'll just work
with us this season the next season we
want to do chubacabras and flying
saucers and i said i have no proof that
super coppers are flying saucers and
that was trying to get me to you know be
paid off or whatever in my view they
didn't say that that's what it was
so they wanted to do that video this is
important it's viral everywhere you guys
can add it here you have an
authorization oh it's live but you want
to add it to post video later sure you
you
you have us in that censored video they
even took off tevo and off the dvrs when
it aired about fema camps
i had general stubblebine the former
head three star general of the army
former head of special operations his
wife who was a head doctor for uh heads
of state
tell me about the calling and the virus
and the painted vaccine so i'm telling
them
here's the guy here's the person here's
how they'll release a virus then release
a vaccine that destroys your immune
system here's the plan so i mean i was
giving him the form
you don't get a good sorry
i found the video
uh sorry i just found the video that you
you were mentioning i just found it you
know play anytime you want yeah got it
put it in post i play it right now
is that stubblebind didn't just head up
the army or army special operations he
ran the black projects
so that's why they did men who stare at
goats by the same guy i talked about
earlier ron said that makes up stories
to make it a joke uh with
all those big actors that i love by the
way jeff bridges and people is to make a
joke out of it but that's where all that
came out of so the head of psychological
warfare the head of psyops
told me all this
i said you should come on the show he
did come on
he said i'm too sick he was in panama
we got his wife to fly up and say what
happened the reason i knew it is because
highest level intelligence chief
told us this so of course it came true
stubbleblind's dead now but it happened
so that's where i get my information and
and and in the show we tell you where we
got it here's me i'm not like going like
nostradamus oh i know this information
and i'm so powerful i know it i'm like
here's where it is here's what they're
doing let's stop it and the frustration
is you either get attacked or people go
oh my god you're magic how do you know
all this and i'm like uh
here it is
so you're what you're what i'm getting
from this is that maybe he was just
doing a tv show for a paycheck and that
you were doing all the work and that he
may not have been a true believer of a
lot of the not trusting government stuff
he was more of a just hey we get to do
this show and i get a paycheck for a
while
and then he just like you said he kind
of goes with the flow
i mean i mean i mean
but i'll tell you the one i'd like to
know what the heart machines are doing
that was my that's everybody's favorite
episode of all time when he was yelling
at yelling outside of the harp place
exactly i knew back then
that he wasn't
not dumb but just not conscious
but
he was like i'm not taking that shot i
know what happened with the anthrax shot
the troops i know about medical
experimentation we're at dinner alex i'm
eating steaks with him and his wife in
vegas where they shot it yeah alex
you're right damn i don't know and then
next he's like anybody doesn't take it
should be arrested yeah that was they
should put whatever they want in our
body no i mean i think he's a sellout
it broke our hearts
it broke our hearts because i always
kind of liked jesse ventura for years
and we watched a clip of him on rt
saying just shut up and take the shot it
was like what is what happened to him
yeah i mean i think he's a has been
that thought i can say it's good shot
and do it or maybe i take shot it's good
i'm with the government now i just even
torah but i mean just all i can say is
you guys know how to bring it up because
i haven't attacked mcconaughey or him
but they are both
ladies and gentlemen absolutely
disgusting
and so you know
ventura will have to live the rest of
his life
with the fact that he is an
establishment [ __ ]
and you know that's his problem so i
just say this [ __ ] you jesse ventura too
ventura is a piece of [ __ ] yeah i alex
man we really appreciate you appreciate
it thank you thank you so much man
really for us uh
this is wonderful dude we really
appreciate it we got to get up to austin
and see you guys in the censored info at
infowars.com and banned video and we're
on every day 11 a.m the 3 p.m you guys
were on yesterday with owen i appreciate
you and thanks for having me on and uh
liberty or death ladies and gentlemen
god bless you all the answer to 1984 is
1776 and i'll see you at infowars.com
where the tip of the spear lives thank
you alex appreciate it buddy take it
easy have a good job dagger at the
camera you know what here you go go for
it go for it don't break it though all
right it's camera two okay camera two
can i
can no one's in no one's in the studio
right
now i'm gonna hit that she knows
stop it i'm gonna hit the camera
i'm gonna hit camera two with this
dagger okay let's go into the studio
right okay okay here we go you're going
to the studio
oh nailed it whoo i hit the top of the
camera
you're still not losing it all right
take it easy alex take care
[ __ ] matthew mcconaughey love america
what would desantis
infowars.com
take it easy take it easy alex nailed it
twice he nailed it and he hit the post
and he got a plug-in say alex bye-bye
oh and there goes alex jones that was uh
that was something
well
did you
can i say it
are you not entertained